hey hey guys welcome back to the channel
and as you can probably tell yes like I
said in my last video the overwatch
overwatch as a new update but during the
video while i was editing i completely
forgot to mention this they now have a
new game mode called Lucille Ball it's
basically think of rocket League but
instead of colors is Lucy oh so I was
like you know what I'll do some gameplay
of it for people that I haven't played
yet so basically the details are it's
3v3 lucio the game is four minutes long
and basically you just score the you
take a ball and you shockwave it are you
kick it into the net and you score then
whoever has the most points wins I'll
probably play one match maybe two
probably just one though I'll try to
make this as short as possible this
should be going up tomorrow the card
hell it should be today for you people
that are watching this because i'm
recording it the day after so basically
as you can tell this is this basically
reminds me of rocket League one hundred
percent there is no using your little
gun you don't shoot your little waves
anymore it's your RT is your punch if
you go on these little yellow pads you
can jump higher you can still use the
speed boost you can't switch it to
healing I don't know why you would The
Ultimates doesn't really make sense
anyway either so I'm gonna see if I can
try to get a goal in our team oh let's
go let's [ __ ] go too easy so glad I
got it now when I was recording and not
the game before I did this because I
played a game before and I scored on my
own goal like twice I had no idea what
the hell I was doing I'm so glad I got
it now let's go team
alright in this come on number two nope
good Mon [ __ ] I missed I still keep
forgetting that the shock wave doesn't
have a lot of range so it's very
difficult to determine when to hit it
because as you could as you just saw I
easily could have scored that but I
misjudged it a bit go teammate for Drago
oh [ __ ]
damn it that's fine we're tied 1-1 you
can come back or we can break this tie I
can't even see the ball half the time
when I play this thank God doesn't mark
where is it this should definitely have
changed it to where like his speed is
like his little was it his amp it up for
his speed is like unlimited because
you're you have playing as Lucio your
kind of slow compared to how fast this
ball spins other than that I really like
this week we brawl well come on to [ __ ]
oh yeah ultimate does absolutely nothing
uh what what oh I scored
up okay I'll take it you guys can
understand basically the basis of this
game this game mode come on oh [ __ ] I
should have jumped damn damn damn all
right
well we have a minute and a half to
break the tie breaker again damn it dude
no get it out [ __ ]
great I was a long shot one or that was
a long shot to dim all right 30 seconds
we can come back oh what a shot
off the wall come on don't give it that
[ __ ] [ __ ] no don't don't bring your
back
oh no aah whatever GG all right I tried
and what I think is great is that the
play of the game it actually shows a
goal in my opinion this is the only way
that lucio can get play of the game it's
just this game mode now
II well that's Lucy of Alton I hope you
guys didn't enjoy that I had a blast
play in this guy I'm gonna play this
game motor and after I've done recording
this this is way too much fun uh anyway
you guys did enjoy leave a like on the
video comment your opinion or come in
your opinion about Lucille Ball I then
that subscribe really helps up this
channel and plus if you subscribed you
can see new videos when they come out
and have a good day guys peace out